this morning aviation industry leaders
are testifying before congress about a
record surge of violent passenger
incidents on flights and at airports
most of this trouble came after the
introduction of rules requiring
passengers to wear masks because of
coven errol barnett spoke exclusively
with the faa administrator that steve
dixon about this bad behavior that's
putting it lightly errol this morning
he's at washington's reagan national
airport errol good morning
good morning tony you are right today's
congressional hearing will explore new
ways of addressing this unprecedented
unruly behavior being witnessed across
the country all year so we asked the faa
administrator why nine months into this
issue they're still looking for ideas
for ways to calm conflict in the skies
from a flight attendant being punched in
the face to passengers fighting each
other violence is being witnessed on
planes and at the gate this year
where does this rank in your worry list
this is right near the top all this
despite the best efforts of faa
administrator steve dixon who
implemented a zero tolerance policy in
january when it became clear air travel
in an ongoing pandemic was becoming
unpredictable the fines that we have
publicized over a million dollars in
fines so far
and the communication that we've done
with the public have driven those rates
down but there's still a lot of work to
be done speaking exclusively to cbs news
dixon says his agency's data shows the
number of unruly incidents per flight
decreased after fines were introduced in
february then plateaued over the summer
thanks to public service announcements
like this
you can distract the pilot if it gets
that bad that is so unsafe
but with more than 4 300 incidents this
year and counting mostly over mask
mandates dixon acknowledges more action
is needed we're still
a good two to three times above where we
need to be and so we've still got
additional work to do and you won't see
alcohol sales return to southwest or
american airlines this year both
suspending service due to problematic
passengers what's your view on that i
think the alcohol bans have been helpful
as you said a lot of these events do
have an alcohol component to them and
that has been one
aspect that's helped us helped us to
drive the rate down
now the faa is also encouraging airports
like this one to limit alcohol to go
sales american airlines says it's
already making some progress at its us
hubs meanwhile at today's congressional
hearing expect to hear flight attendants
testify to the high level of anxiety
many of them now experience on a daily
basis scale either from these unruly
incidents or in anticipation of them
taking place
i understand the anxiety thank you very
much errol